so leute auf ein neues hallo ich hätte
gerne einen cheeseburger
ja ich habe jetzt mal eine gute idee und
zwar ich verstehe meine stimme so ein
bisschen
[Musik]
hallo ich hätte gern einmal cheeseburger
hey leute was geht ab und jetzt
willkommen bei anderen video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut jetzt wird es
irgendwie schon wieder heller das ist
also es besser oder vier tagen also kam
er das video fünfmal in einer stunde
beim lieferservice bestellen wo ich fünf
mal beim lieferservice bestellt
wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt
schaut euch das gerne jetzt noch eben an
oder halt dann danach ist auf jeden fall
in der video beschreibung verlinkt und
dort habe ich den kommentar gelesen alex
warum fährst du dich einfach fünfmal
durch mcdrive und bestellt jedes mal das
gleiche also die gleiche challenge alt
nur diesmal im mac 3 und ich dachte erst
so ja so diese typischen mcdonald's
banks ist eigentlich nicht so mein
lieblings content habe mich dann aber
doch überwunden und wieder kommen macht
es einfach mal ist ja nichts schlimmes
bei ich meine ich bin ja nicht als ich
oder so und deswegen habe ich das
einfach mal durchgezogen ich will doch
eigentlich gar nicht lange lover ich
wünsche euch viel spaß mit dem video
und ja es ist meiner meinung nach
wirklich was sehr unerwartetes passiert
was ich so auf kleinsten gedachte
abonniert den kanal schreibt gerne ideen
für weitere challenges die ich so noch
wahlen kann in die kommentare
ist immer ganz wichtig und würde ich
sagen letzte leute dann würde ich sagen
wir machen uns mal auf den weg was
vergessen
ich brauche noch geht weil ich finde es
ganz ganz wichtig das darf auf keinen
fall passieren dass da jemand die kamera
erkennt weil dann ist das ganze
irgendwie stressig wenn ich besser
wollen die rum
deswegen müssen wir die gleiche sehr gut
verstecken ich hoffe das klappt und in
manchen fällen muss ich dir aber auch
unternehmen damit dass schon mal gesagt
ist so jetzt aber los leute eigentlich
wollte die cam einmal hier positionieren
und hier mit diesem habe ich extra
geholt das ist wie so pater fix oder so
das hält hier drauf halt wirklich
überhaupt nicht sagt mich jetzt gerade
ein bisschen ab deswegen glaube ich was
ich die kamera halt einfach halten und
sie dann irgendwie hier platzieren ich
weiß aber noch nicht wie das ist mir
nämlich einfach ein zu hohes risiko wenn
ihr hier stehe und da die mc drive oder
der mc drive arbeiter ist dass man das
halt direkt sieht weil das ist immer das
blöde bei so was ich habe so was
ähnliches ja schon mal gemacht mit felix
schöne grüße an dich und da wurde das
auch halt direkt entdeckt und das möchte
ich nicht einfach weil das halt schnell
zu problemen führen kann deswegen würde
ich sagen wir improvisieren einfach
schnell und dann hoffe ich dass das für
euch okay also erfahren los ich muss
erst mal geld von der bank letzte
so leute geld ist abgeholt wir haben
jetzt 20 und 30 also es wird jetzt
gleich leider schon dunkel
ganz wichtig was ich auf jeden fall noch
sagen wollte dann werde ich natürlich
wie auch bei den pizza video immer das
gleiche bestellen ich habe investoren
dürfen zwar ein erdbeer shake ein
cheeseburger und butter kartoffeln und
behörden mal sehen ich bin jetzt auch
schon da und auf geht's das erste mal
mal gucken was passiert ich bin gespannt
hallo ich hätte gern einen cheeseburger
ein erdbeer shake eine kleine was ist
mit sohn einfach so und die gitter
kartoffeln das wäre es auch schon
dankeschön frieden haben 77 euro ganz
klein
dankeschön haben gleich weiter positiv
ja habe ich danke danke schön
so leute also erster bundes durch ich
hoffe das licht ist ja okay es wird echt
dunkel es komplett dunkel das tut mir
wirklich leid hier ist gerade für das
fußballspiel deswegen hat er gesagt
passt auch die fußballfans darauf
wirklich sehr cooler typ
ich würde sagen wir düsen jetzt einfach
noch einmal durch und dann habe ich
gedacht könnte ich auch einfach mal so
eine cap aufsetzen oder so und mal
gucken ob sie das überhaupt checken
also wir sehen uns gleich also der
schmeckt auf jeden fall ganz nah er hat
mir irgendwas von der soße erzählt habe
ich noch nie gehört was soll ja für eine
soße drauf mal gucken ob jetzt schon
irgendwas lustiges passiert leute ich
habe die kamera jetzt einfach hier an
der tür angebracht weil da kann ich auch
absolut keiner sehen ich weiß nicht wie
die perspektive ist aber das muss jetzt
mit dem zweiten versuch reichen also
eigentlich müsste dass ich jetzt schon
denken wieso kommt der typ noch mal
bestellt doch mal genau das vielleicht
noch kartoffeln
nein einfach so einzelne kleine einfach
so wieder
ich frage mich jetzt ob ich einfach
direkt nochmal rein fahren soll oder ob
ich jetzt meine cap aufziehen soll ich
hatte jetzt wirklich 100 euro darauf
gewettet dass er mich fragte ob ich
schon mal hier oder dankeschön leute was
geht zweiter durchgang ist geschafft ich
war jetzt in zehn minuten zweimal da ich
fahre jetzt einfach direkt um ein
drittes mal dann war ich in 15 minuten
drei mal da und wenn er jetzt wieder nix
checkt fahrrad ein viertes mal und also
eigentlich hatte ich gedacht so fünfmal
wir beim letzten video auch es kann aber
natürlich auch sein dass sehr viele
menschen gitter kartoffeln milch shake
und cheeseburger bestellen und dann
fällt das nicht so auf aber das glaube
ich eigentlich nicht wir werden sehen
ich bin gespannt dritter durchgang
let's go ich habe jetzt mal eine gute
idee und zwar ich verstehe meine stimme
so ein bisschen an die die sich denken
vielleicht schenken das nicht weil so
viel los ist nein also vielleicht sind
in der zeit jetzt zwei drei andere autos
dadurch gefallen aber das ja nicht viel
los
kleine kinder kartoffeln
caramel das wäre
bestimmte
wie man den berühmten letzten zehn
partien
es stimmt so danke
somit das geht doch gar nicht
ich komme gar nicht klar vielleicht
können wir ja noch hier
danke leute das kann doch nicht dein
ernst sein oder
also ich meine das kann ja mal passieren
dass oder also vielleicht sagt er ja
auch extra nix aber das glaube ich nicht
also ich würde ja merken einer komisch
gucken würde dass er mich halt trat
schon zweimal gesehen hat in den letzten
zehn minuten vor allem dann auch noch
mal ich ja die ganze zeit konnten genau
das gleiche stelle aber ich kann euch
auch nicht versprechen dass wir
irgendwas aufregendes passiert wenn
nämlich einfach die ganze zeit nicht
erkennt neulich war ganz schwach zu
hause haben wir die mütter geholt weil
ich wohne nicht so weit weg von darf
aber ich glaube dass ich dir einfach ab
lasse weil dj schon jetzt nichts mehr
mit 21 6 und ich weiß das vierte mal
also wirklich so das vierte mal in einer
halben stunde und die drei mal am anfang
waren halt komplett aufeinanderfolgen
ich bin jetzt will ich mal gespannt ob
jetzt irgend ein dummer kommentare
kommen weil der typ ich gucke ihn auch
die ganze zeit so an weise also ist für
mich so ein großes rätsel also das ja
nicht mal irgendwie sagt ist weil die
alles in ordnung also bei dem pizza
video auch sohn ist ja natürlich logisch
so leute auf ein neues
hallo ich hätte gerne einen cheeseburger
einmal gitter kartoffeln und
erdbeermilch säcklein das war's schon
bin ich jetzt dumm oder war dies eine
andere stimme also wenn das jetzt auch
andere stimmen also hey das war das gar
nicht mein tag heute ist glaube ich
jetzt nicht der typ ist irgendwie ans
werk gemacht hat ist jetzt einfach kein
mittel der da leute das ist doch so eine
ist war ich kurz zu hause und genau in
der zeit schließen die hinten diesem
schalter der chip arbeitet jetzt vorne
und da ist ein ganz anderer am herzen
mir tut es wirklich sehr leid ich hätte
mir auch eine lustige reaktion der
häufigkeit nicht irgendein krasse
reaktion herbeizaubern
also der typ wirklich engadin hat es
überhaupt nicht gejuckt oder er war halt
was gesichter angeht und stimmen er hat
mich hat auch schon wieder angeguckt auf
jeden fall nicht der hellste sagen was
man so leute hier bei uns in der nähe
trifft manchmal nachts hatte ich jetzt
noch ein cheeseburger über oder sich
bestimmt gefreut das nehme ich jetzt
nicht mit ins video war mit ihr sagt
alex du hast aber liebt dir sondern
einfach formal essenberg schmeißt gibt
genug leute die sich eigentlich drüber
freund also denk dran nicht ordentlich
essen wegzuschmeißen
das sollte was ich kurz auch sagen
wollte ich bin jetzt wieder zu hause ich
hätte natürlich anderes fünften mal
durchfahren könnte heisst und wird sich
ein anderer typ der hat wahrscheinlich
dann gesagt hey du warst du grad shimada
aber das war jetzt auch nichts krass
gewesen braucht man noch weiter aufbauen
kann und ich will jetzt auch nicht
stumpf einfach da weiter essen kaufen
was ich danach im endeffekt nicht
loswerden oder so ist zwar alles bis auf
der letzte schießen blogger weggekommen
also hat jemand vergessen kann ich
versprechen aber ich habe jetzt mehr
sondern auch keinen bock mehr ich weiß
ich denke ich schreibe ihnen titel
fünfmal als wird halt viermal weil die
challenger an sich fünfmal ist nehmen
wir das nicht übel das soll ja so oft im
netz video aufbauen
ansonsten masters vom video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen ist nach oben da trägt
auf jeden fall morgen das video auf was
online kommt um 19 uhr wird denke ich
mal
noch cooler als dies hier gerade auch
was eine bestellung zu tun das was mir